oh that's crazy oh i know why because he
probably wants weaker dudes
dude i've heard of that so i just
started stand up a year ago i can't
believe a year ago i can't believe it
first show a year ago wow for i've never
done an open mic nothing so we i sold
out a tour and the first show i had was
the first time i've ever been on stage
what
how did you test that
do it i didn't
i just rehearsed it in my bedroom and
then just got up there and was just
praying to god that it worked yeah how
much time did you do i do i do when i
started i had like 30 minutes now i have
45. oh wow
and so you went up for
30 minutes the first time you ever went
i've been doing comedy 30 years i can
barely do 30 minutes
wow and were you nervous oh hell yes
hell yes you're pacing and it's finally
calmed down after a year now i feel like
normal like i can you know walk on stage
normally but oh god i was about to die
the first six months yeah
wow yeah and how did you write you just
just go through your gut instinct i just
so i perform as trailer trash tammy
but everything i you know all my bits
like are true stories that have happened
to me i just tell them you know
yeah so i just [ __ ] spent like a year
just writing and just literally just
hoping like man i hope this works wow
goosebumps i'm getting goosebumps too
that's amazing and it and it did so i'm
just gonna keep on because it's the
scariest thing
anyone can do how old were you when you
did it
i'm uh 33 i'm 34. so at 34 years old
doing it for the first time and you're
not doing an open mic you're headlining
right i mean
it's your audience yeah right what club
was it
first show i think we did dallas i think
we did hyenas in dallas oh hyenas yeah i
love that one
and then um are you doing all the other
clubs now
now we we're doing theaters now
yeah i've been 30 years old i can't even
do a theater
insane stop yeah i swear i don't do
theaters i like theaters better than um
better than uh clubs big time why
because you can do one show well yeah
but my audience are [ __ ] crazy
like when i say crazy like they're they
will rush the stage
they will interrupt me all [ __ ] night
yeah um it's hard for me to get through
a set because they're talking to me
they won't they don't sit there and
listen they they want to interact big
time and i'm trying to do my set so i
get very annoyed so i will tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up but you're doing a
funny way shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know
what i mean i'm trying to do you know
what i mean yep yeah i mean i'm sorry no
and they love that too yeah yeah but in
a theater setting
great impressions y'all y'all y'all shut
the [ __ ] up great and somebody yeah yeah
yeah
um
in a theater setting they're they act
better
they act better in a theater because
you're right because it's like
i was at the ontario problem maybe three
years ago and who opened for me with
sandy danto
and you know sandy dante oh yeah
he's weird-looking i love him
imagine if
you put john um
john belushi in a microwave oh okay wow
i got to google this guy that's what he
looks like oh okay oh i have okay yeah i
do know who he is
yeah anyway um
i think it was danto and
three minutes in
it's just fists flying
sandy kicking people off the stage yeah
cholos hey puto you know
it was just chaos right and i'm like
you know i'm used to that environment
yeah but it's like i just can't do it
anymore but my point is is that that's
essentially what happens at clubs
sometimes it's like second show people
get drunk it gets wild and it's like as
a young man because you know i used to
i'm much like you i think you and i are
very similar in uh in um
how do you speak spirit yeah
you like your nudist i'm a nudist yeah
you're a man me too yeah yeah that's why
i think we should do the calendar let's
do it yeah dead serious i'm dead serious
too
um and i think they'll sell like
hotcakes
um but my point is is that um so when
you're
like us
in those environments we can survive but
it's like when you and now i'm 50. it's
like i don't want to survive that no
more man yeah you know what i mean are
you 50
yeah
whoa
you don't look 50 my man you know what
they say asian
don't rain no feet finish it asian well
i was gonna say asian don't crack but
that's black
that's exactly what it is it was it
really don't raisin
i was close
track you not
you got available um
was that the first dude you [ __ ]
um no